Speaker 1: There's a guy named Charles Herb,
Mr. He's running for state Senate and he's
running for Senate.
Well, what is he running for?
We're going to figure out in a second.
He has been accused of groping more than six
women, and he has been very strongly endorsed
by Donald Trump.
Vanity Fair piece by Best 11 Charles Herbst,
who insists he's the victim of a smear campaign
trying to destroy him with lies.
Bess Levin writes, Donald Trump isn't great
at a lot of stuff.
But one thing he absolutely excels, excels
at is endorsing horrible people for office.
Since 2016, a who's who of Trump backed candidates
has included Roy reportedly banned from the
mall more.
Lauren, I'll share my carry my Glock to Congress.
Boebert, Herschel.
If evolution is real, why do apes still exist?
Walker?
Ron.
Don't say gay.
DeSantis.
Memmott have some snake oil.
Matt human trafficking is fine.
Gates and Mary Hitler actually had a good
idea.
Miller in October, a guy running for Oh, it's
Nebraska governor named Charles Herbstreit,
got himself added to the list.
He has a habit of allegedly groping women.
The Nebraska Examiner reported Thursday eight
women say her pastor groped them, writing
that six women said he touched them inappropriately
when they were saying hello or goodbye, or
when posing for a photograph by his side.
A seventh accused the candidate of cornering
her in private and forcibly kissing her.
All of the women told the outlet they were
intentionally grabbed, not inadvertently grazed.
In one particularly gross incident, Republican
State Senator Julie Sliema said that her sister
in the middle of a crowded room at an event
for the Douglas County Republican Party, reached
up her skirt and touched her inappropriately
without her consent.
These are allegations, folks.
Remember another person who attended the event
confirmed they saw Herbst or reach up, slam
a skirt and claimed that he also groped another
woman's.
But at the same event at the same event, the
Nebraska Examiner piece is quite disturbing.
Republican state senator and seven other women
say Charles Herbst groped them.
He denies the allegations.
Now, remember that even if you think Trump
as a businessperson is no good, you don't
like Trump's foreign policy.
You don't like Trump's views on immigration
or whatever.
His continued claim to fame and one often
cited by his strongest supporters, is he makes
good choices with hiring.
He hires the right people, he hires the best
people, and he continues to endorse people
accused of or proven to have said horrible
things.
I encourage you to check out the Nebraska
Examiner article by Erin Sandford.
It's very extensive, it's very detailed, et
cetera.
Now, the biggest frustration I think that
many of us are having at this point is that
these types of allegations don't matter if
the electorate that supports you doesn't care
about them or only cares about them when they
are allegations against Democrats.
And that's basically what we have seen.
I mean, at this point, I'm curious to hear
from people in the audience.
Do allegations like this matter at all anymore?
Trump was accused.
You know, even the No is a hard number to
say.
Trump was accused very specifically of what
we would call sexual assault type behaviors
by around a dozen women.
But then subsequently we learned about allegations
of a more kind of broader scope from more
than 40 women.
And he talked about grab them by the, you
know, white and all these.
You just do it and all these different things.
And he was elected president in 2016.
He was he was really elected.
And we can say, well, part of it was Hillary
wasn't a great candidate and, you know, these
different things, but the side that claims
to be about family values and all of these
things has not cared about it when it's Trump
and they excuse it away.
Well, Hillary's worse.
Or what am I going to do?
Stay home?
Or those are lies.
It's fake news.
All these different things.
So does it even matter when their side is
accused of this stuff?
And we've also talked before about how sometimes
to show how much not like them, we are the
left sometimes goes overboard.
I think the greatest example is the Al Franken
situation.
Al Franken.
You know, he he took a distasteful picture
and it was inappropriate and it was wrong,
and he apologized and all of these different
things.
But immediately, many prominent Democrats
said Al Franken must resign.
And he did.
And Democrats lost what was a good senator.
And I'm not defending what Al Franken did,
but I'm pointing out the scale of what he
did is nothing compared to what many of these
Republicans have been accused of or have been
proven to have done.
And it may almost be a fault of the left that
it so quickly goes to.
We're not going to be like them.
We're going to clean house the same way they
should be cleaning house.
Yeah, but they're never going to do it.
And I don't know what the exact right balance
is to find, but they don't seem to care about
any of this stuff.
And so there's a real question as to how the
left should manage and react to it.
Let me know your thoughts.
I don't.
I don't know what what the right strategy
is.